I hate the picture
[Music]
all I see is a young man in the process
of losing his life
Michael was my big brother Michael
Matthews from Fulham became the youngest
Britain to conquer Mount Everest he was
left alone on the mountain
he'd die
the odd years later was sent this
photograph of a body it looks like it
could be Michael it might be my ass is
we should go find it and if we can bring
him home
stay safe if you get a hold of mate I
hear his voice screaming that one now I
need the best people possible we have
one of the greatest Nims Persia we have
to meet all over the mountain
I hope
this is one of the highest search and
Recovery missions in history on average
seven people every year for those
attempting Everest will lose their lives
second time over
[Music]
foreign